frankly people want to hear the
challenges it's you know they do what
we're doing here is very much like
making a film you know it's it's like
what are the challenges you know what
did you try and failed at and came back
and sprang back into life for and
overcame that hurdle
to get to what you wanted the most
when did you have the idea that you
wanted to be a travel filmmaker uh yeah
travel and filmmaking
It's a combination of things that is
eternally exciting uh for some reason
it's been my
Fascination dedication Obsession since I
was
15. I first went to Europe with a band
when I was in high school for three
months and that got me hooked on travel
forever so when you travel when you're
young especially it'll stay a part of
your life for the entire run of your
life
so as I knew that I was wanted to see
possibly every country in the world if I
could possibly do it
and then I also fell in love with
filmmaking so I wanted to combine those
two
travel and filmmaking and so like many
filmmakers that were in love with
National Geographic shows the BBC uh
collect all those National Geographics
when I was young and uh dream about
going to these places and making films
and these uh great countries around the
world so I started doing that when um
right out of college really you know I
was
shooting I got an assignment I've worked
with Runners World magazine when I was
20 21 and I convinced them to send me to
Europe you see for a year
On Assignment to cover different
marathons and running events and of
course while I was there I was filming
cheese makers of Switzerland tapestry
makers of Spain you know just all violin
makers in England so I was interested
right away when I was 20 to combine this
filmmaking with the international travel
life
I'm not sure whether curiosity comes
from because uh my mother's never been
on a plane ever and my father was a
travel but only during World War II so
that's not much in the sense of travel
and culture he was on a ship but my uh
my brothers and sister were never that
interested at all in travel so I don't
know why people are inspired to do
certain things in their life versus
their siblings or parents but for me it
was always just a need to get out there
and do a National Geographic shows or
documentaries and almost every filmmaker
I've ever run into wants to do a feature
film at some point a dramatic film a
movie you know it's so romantic to do
that in a sense when you're young so I
always wanted to do a feature film when
I was very young but I didn't have the
capacity to do it so I focused on travel
adventure shows and documentaries
since I was 20 essentially
what type of temperament and mindset
does a travel filmmaker have to have
yeah a temperament for the ideal travel
filmmaker number one
if you're going to dedicate your life to
seeing the world studying the world
traveling to these places around the
planet it's a lot like a sailor's life
you you have to be
forego a lot of the things that a normal
person that with a happy family at home
and maybe a house maybe that's not going
to happen for you because it can be
incredibly disruptive to have maintain a
relationship at home if you're out there
you know in Zanzibar making a
documentary or something what happens to
your partner at home you know they're
you get together as a couple so that you
can literally be together spend your
life together enjoying things together
but if you're so separate that can drive
a wedge between your relations
relationships and so it's very hard on
families if you are a dedicated Gypsy
Adventurer filmmaker unless you can
somehow devise a way to travel with your
uh you know partner then that's ideal
actually then you take your home with
you in that sense but if you have family
if you have a kid or two kids or
something that's almost impossible to do
that as a filmmaker so there's going you
have to make a deal with yourself to
to figure out what is the strongest pull
uh the biggest Obsession in your life
if it's if your need is to get out there
and make films around the world you have
to make peace with that and not complain
about that not whine about it you just
have to go do that and follow your dream
and you just hope that the rest of your
life
can stay in parallel or synchronize with
that as you go through your life
sometimes it doesn't work a lot of
filmmakers that travel half the year in
different countries the world they it's
almost impossible to maintain that
relationship at home so there's a lot of
divorces in this case with a lot of
people I know anyway sometimes they just
stay Bachelors for their all their lives
you know if that's what they do
filmmakers and photographers I know that
travel for half the year or more
and and dealing with peer and family
judgment I'm sure is is something you
know if you come back for Thanksgiving
and oh yeah when are you going to settle
down why not that's always a that's
always a big uh challenge isn't it when
you get together at holidays with your
family and each of the siblings and the
parents are so different than you are
and you're you're the black sheep of the
family and it's it's so difficult to
even find a common ground of things to
talk about topics you know and so yeah
you definitely run into some
interference at times from uh from
family members but sometimes that's a
bit of an inspiration in a way my father
even though I I did uh like him very
much I'm sure I loved him but it wasn't
this hugging kind of relationship he was
uh like I said he didn't understand what
I was doing and making films he couldn't
get his head wrapped around the concept
of why are you making these films how do
you expect to make money and so we never
ever really got along too well and so
that was always a bit of friction we
just never had anything in common but I
looked at his life though as not a life
necessarily well spent because I think
he just get got caught up in in raising
a family with four kids and he was an
air traffic controller he didn't have
any particular passion with that job and
he would work odd shifts night shifts
graveyard shifts so and then he got let
go because of cataracts and so I saw him
as a very unsatisfied man in later life
and I just as a reverse model I thought
that was probably good for me to see
that in the sense of I don't want to
become the person just in the Rock
rocking chair watching television when
you're 50 or 60 all of your life
way too young yeah it does it was very
unfortunate to see that but um
but again you know just like any artist
filmmakers uh if you're obsessed with it
if it's something that you have to do
that's what artists do they will paint
they will write they will uh do theater
they'll do dancing even if there isn't
an immediate audience or immediate money
for it you are compelled to do it and
that's the same thing with the filmmaker
you better feel compelled and driven to
do it otherwise you better get out and
get out now
and choose another career because
there's too many obstacles to be
successful for a life of filmmaking
money making filmmaking there's too many
obstacles
if you're not obsessed and strong and
have those blinders on that's the only
way a film will get done is if you or if
you're a small little team or so driven
to do it it will fail if you do not
keep your vision strong and clear it
will fail there's no question
and especially if you're doing something
you think is very very good you know
just go ahead and also things will fail
and you have to maybe try again with
something brand new yeah that's true
yeah and that's again the sense of if
you are too focused on just one film one
topic one project if you're too focused
and too obsessed with it
it's uh let's hope it works out for you
uh if it doesn't for some reason uh it
can kind of destroy your life or you'll
give up so that's why I you know again
it's it's wise to have a healthy uh set
of other options for stories available
and nearly ready to go if that one
project that is your you think is your
magnum opus your Masterpiece if you're
not able to do it this year maybe take
that second project and do it you know
it's if it's a little bit easier to
accomplish to assemble the team to do
that second movie instead of that
Masterpiece you wanted to do don't worry
about just just go ahead and
pivot pivot to these other projects and
don't um you know just don't say this is
the only thing or nothing
that's not really a good way to go it's
not healthy at all to have that plan so